well it looks like sagaa has reached an
agreement with the amtp now much like
with the wga this has to be ratified but
I expect that that will be the case I'm
not going to have a full video going
over this until sometime next week
because the details are not going to be
made public until probably Friday but I
expect that it went very much in the
actor's favor I think it's a very big
sign that a little while ago the
producers came and said this is our last
and best final offer and the actor said
no and then the amtp came back a few
days later and obviously had changed
their last and best final offer while
they held out a little bit longer than I
expected after collapsing to the wga it
pretty much mirrors the same thing the
actors made it clear like no we're not
going to let you get away with what you
with what we told you isn't
okay and they eventually realized they
weren't going to win we'll find out the
details soon but overall
yeah